[Music]
nicole is in traverse city michigan hi
nicole how are you
good how are you today better than i
deserve what's up
so i'm just wondering is
it a good time to
take my home bakery business and move it
into a commercial space
um as a bakery and breakfast and lunch
cafe during like this economy and this
weird like
times that we're going through
i think the answer to that might be
um more local
than not
uh
translation um i live in a county
in tennessee
that is wide open
and um
there's very little
activity in this county that is in any
way restricted at this moment
um
and it's a fairly
pre-pandemic looking feeling when you
walk down the street or when you go into
a store
okay
other areas of the country that i visit
um
i was in five states in the last a few
months in the last uh last
15 days i guess something like that
and i've been in several states that uh
uh i felt like i was back in the middle
of the pandemic again because they're
very shut down and very closed up and
very
um there and that environment is going
to be difficult to operate a bakery and
agreed and i i know traverse city it's a
wonderful city and i suspect you guys
are pretty wide open it's a resort area
and uh my friend meg meeker lives there
and and uh you know it's a it's a great
area uh and so i suspect the city itself
is probably pretty open uh you are in
the state of michigan which is cray-cray
right now
but um
on this issue but uh but that's that's
the environment you have to ask yourself
this question in right
yeah so if the governor leaves you alone
is traverse city going to leave you
alone and let you operate
okay yeah i mean i feel like
everything's been pretty open around
here and that's been the general route
that we seem to be headed towards yeah
but i mean
again if if every time
there's a spike in cases they shut down
businesses like yours this is a bad
environment starting agreed
yes because you're going to burn up
capital on rent that is unproductive
you're going to burn up capital on
electricity you're going to lose stock
because you can't get it baked and out
the door
um and you can't get workers
um yeah and that kind of stuff so but if
you can operate fairly freely
maybe not a hundred percent but 80 or 90
percent with freedom
to have a quote normalized operation
unquote that gives you a predictable
environment
to do business in
and uh when you when you
interfere with the predictable
environment it makes it difficult to do
business that's what politicians don't
understand
and
it affects jobs it affects supply routes
it affects everything when they screw
with it
uh but they're dumb and they don't know
these things so um you just have to just
have to laugh your head and laugh and
shake your head at them but that you
know so to the extent you feel like that
freedom is gonna that they're gonna give
they're gonna stay off of you
and let you operate is to the extent yes
now is a very good time
because everything that is open is
booming
and so we've got shortages of everything
because everything that's open is
booming anywhere in america and so
it just depends on the environment that
you're sitting in and um
you know how messed up they are
um
so uh and how you know and it's
fear-based and i mean they're afraid
and i understand they're afraid i get
that and they don't want somebody hurt
nobody wants anybody to be sick i get
all that
that's not the point but the point is
you've got to have a
um a predictable environment in order to
do business
so it's a good question if you've got
that i think it's a great time